I cannot wait for the next Star Trek
because you're making the next one yeah
we shot the the next Star Trek movie and
we are editing the film now and you know
we're friends and I want to do something
special for the the show so I actually
brought a clip from the new movie
you brought a clip yeah you know this is
a movie that you haven't even finished
assembly where we reading it right now
but I mean people gonna freak out to see
this clip they're gonna go and say I
just want I just thought it'd be fun to
bring a clip that's it's matte they're
the internet's gonna they're gonna
they're gonna lose their minds tell us
how he does this clip well if that's the
things a paramount was really unhappy
with me at the idea of bringing anything
and I really told my I really wanted to
do it and they said what it's gotta be
really short I said okay if I can bring
one they said yes it has mythic it can't
be longer than three frames
you've brought a clip that's three
frames long these three frames but it's
they're all there
this is but these are real frames these
are three frames from the film but I
into beginning a middle and a three okay
you know what I still believe that
people are going to maybe freeze-frame
this on their computer and study it and
dissected people out they're gonna be
like I must examine it that was me by
the way should we see this we need to
sit need a set up I'm not sure what we
brought no I'm kidding of course it
everything this is no this is a scene
where a Spock who's the you know one of
the main characters uh for reasons that
you have to see the film understand has
isn't a volcano in this crazy suit and
he's in this volcano and this is the
scene Spock in a volcano in a crazy suit
let's take a look at this three frame
clip from star trek into darkness
[Applause]
kind of different to me now it's not
like plastic Spock yeah it's alright
you're not a fan of on fires yeah yeah
yeah yeah I don't think I'll see it now